Ngày Hà Mi Bá thống mươi, tổng thống án bình mẹ Putin,
trên bố các biển pháp trường phạt mới của Mỹ nhằm vào 2 tập đoàn dấu khi lớn của ngá
La Rosnath và Luccoi, Lung Hiem Trong, Sông, Kháu Đi, sẽ không anh đường sản gây tới nền kinh tế của ra
phát biểu tại Thủ Đô Mắc Cơ Và. Ông Putin chỉ trích lộm thái của Washington là hàng độn thiếu thân thiệt.
Cần báo viểu phá vữa cân bằng nắng lượng gần câu có thể đầy giả dấu tò mạnh.
Với khó khăn cho các nước tưu thủ lớn trong độ có Mỹ.
Thực tế ngay sau khi ông đường năng trăm công bố lệnh Trung phát nhằm em mắt gờ vào trong rất trễ xử tại uống quay nà.
Giờ dấu thế giới đã tăng gần năng phân trăm, yếu dân nghiệp dầu mỏ Trung Quốc và đổ tụng gả tạm nừng nhập khẩu dầu ngà.
Cũng tại buổi công bố lệnh Trung phát. Tổ thống trông khẳng định sẽ theo dõi các tóc đậu của bị pháp trong sâu tháng tới
lông thời hi vào vọng sẽ không phải áp kế lệnh Trung phà lệnh ngà của lâu.
Ông tròm tụng cho biết kế hoạch gặp ông Putin tại buồn đầy PAS chưa bị loại bỏ hằng toàn.
Trong khi đó ông Putin bây giờ tổ sáng xác bởi thoại, nhưng cạnh báo,
nếu ngà bị tấn công bằng thế lửa tấm xa tôn mò hóc, phản nướng của mắt scova sẽ rất mạnh mẽ,
nếu không mình nói là áp đào.
Nói Mỹ liên mình cho ông cũng vừa thông qua gọi trường phát thử mấy chiến,
bao gồm lệnh cầm nhất khẩu khi tự nhiên hỏi lòng,
lựa nửa gờ của ngà, đúng thời gian gái tiếp tục hổ chợt tại chuyển chủ quyền nha,
trong 2 năm tử.